de retour des bijoux ça t'empêche pas de
m'installer sur mes rideaux une peu
d'intérêt que tu semblais accordé à ce
qu a changé td est sur le point de le
revendre avec l'invention est à 9
[Musique]
elin aux orres était loin d'être ces
reptiles verdâtre pour s'était imaginé
encore aussi que le dernier espèce de
créature à dos des malades il dans le
gigantisme aller de pair avec une
lenteur exaspérante
de nos jours nous savons que de nombreux
dinosaures portaient des plumes certains
de manière très anecdotique alors que
d'autres ont été carrément recouvert et
ça fait maintenant plusieurs années que
de nombreux chercheurs se penchent sur
la coloration ne sais plus c'est vrai et
c'est à peu près tout ce qu'on peut en
dire au vrai monde comparé à ce qu'on
sait des oiseaux actuels il est clair
que les plumes des dinosaures n'étaient
pas seulement noire et blanche mais
aussi jaune bleue verte rouge
ils m'ont beaucoup de couleurs dans sa
reconstruction donc tout ça c'est bien
beau mais on est encore loin de la
construction parfaite et en couleur de
nos dinosaures à plumes à ce serait bien
si c'était le cas et pour mieux
comprendre comment ça fonctionne je vous
invite à faire un tour chez nos chers
dinosaures aviens contemporain j'ai
nommé les pioupious les oiseaux sont
considérés comme le groupe de pertes est
vrai le plus coloré du règne animal ses
couleurs en de nombreuses utilisations
que ce soit au niveau de la
reconnaissance visuelle du signalement
de la parade nuptiale ou même encore du
camouflage
on parle aussi du rôle de certaines
couleurs dans la thermorégulation ou
encore pour aider à la rigidité des
primes de vol il ya déjà eu des
centaines de vidéos sur le sujet donc je
vais pas m'étendre là dessus ce qui nous
intéressait aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la
coloration des plumes
elle même d'où viennent ces couleurs
comment se mélangent tel pour donner ses
superbes courant de multicolores qui en
eux les crêtes les plus tendances
pour commencer il est important de
comprendre comment se forme ses couleurs
de plumes et c'est un sujet assez
complexe six oiseaux il existe
différents types de coloration qui se
mélangent pour aboutir au résultat que
l'on connaît
les deux principaux sur la coloration
dit structurel et celles dites
pigmentaire la coloration structurel
n'est pas dû aux pigments elle est due à
la microstructure des plus dans les
plumes se trouve ce qu'on appelle des
mélanosomes ce sont des socios
microscopiques qui contiennent des
pigments selon leur abondance ou leur
absence ainsi que leurs arrangements
dans l'espace la couleur émises par les
plumes var l'exemple le plus criant est
la couleur bleue des plumes de
nombreuses espèces d'oiseaux notamment
du paon ce bleu n'est pas créée par les
pigments mais bien par la microstructure
des plumes
elle même la microstructure des plaines
permet aussi de créer ses reflets
chatoyants que nous serions bien en
peine de reproduire avec de la peinture
on les observe sur le coup défendre mais
aussi sur la gorge du colibri
c'est cette micro structures qui se
retrouvent dans les fossiles les mieux
conservées et uniquement les mieux
conservées on va pas se mentir ça c'est
pas terrible
le problème c'est que les mélanosomes ne
font pas tout et la couleur d'une plume
uni pas du cac cède microstructure que
l'on peut voir au microscope bleus les
verts les jaunes mais entre mot juif ne
viennent pas uniquement des mélanosomes
ils gagnent souvent des pigments eux
mêmes la coloration pigmentaire donc est
obtenue grâce à de vrais pigments tout
comme nos cheveux ou notre peau les
pigments contenu dans le corps de
l'oiseau sont transmis aux plumes lors
de leur pousse une fois la plume en
place il a pu se terminer
il n'est plus possible de changer sa
couleur son action extérieure un peu
comme grande aux chevaux à moins de
méthane
on n'en changera pas la couleur chez les
oiseaux c'est à peu près pareil
à la différence près c'est la vie les
oiseaux contrairement à nous dispose
dans l'arsenal pigmentaire bien plus
développée en quelque sorte oui bien que
tu sois pas exactement ce que
j'appellerais un oiseau noir france mais
les pigments à bien se classent en trois
grandes catégories
la mélanine un peu comme celle qu'on a
en tant qu'humain c'est ce qu'ont
produit quand on bronze en l'occurrence
donc des pigments brin voir noir des
caroténoïdes des pigments oscillant
entre le rouge et le jaune allant
parfois jusqu aux roses et des pigments
plus rare souvent partagé par une seule
famille d'oiseaux est donc assez
caractéristique de la famille
en question on peut retrouver un peu
toutes les couleurs possibles et
imaginables
et c'est là que ça faisait un peu plus
complexe alors accrochez vous à vos
claviers
par rapport à la suite oui voyons un peu
ses pigments de plus près il n'existe
pas une mais deux centres de mélanine le
mail année mais l'année une vraie et la
feo mélanine ces deux couleurs ne sont
pas exactement les mêmes l'eumélanine
donne des couleurs allant du marron noir
donc des couleurs assez foncée est
plutôt terne alors que la feuille en
mélanine
en revanche donne des couleurs plus
rougeâtre des bras un peu rond quand
même dire ou tirant sur le blond comme
chez nous la mélanine est produite par
l'oiseau lui même elle ne vient pas de
son alimentation
la petite subtilité ici et que les deux
types de mélanine ne peuvent pas être
produites en même temps sur la même
plume donc une partie depuis le coloré
de mélanine ne pourra pas contenir de
fait au lit la nuit et inversement
ce sont les fameux mélanosomes qui
contiennent la mélanine chez les oiseaux
et on suppose donc qu'il en allait de
même pour les dinosaures non aviaires
sachant que les mélanosomes montrent une
taille différente en fonction du type de
mai l'année mais qu'ils contiennent il
est facile toutes proportions gardées
cela dit de savoir quel type de mélanine
était contenu dans quelques plumes de
dinosaures
c'est donc grâce à ça qu'on peut
constituer les couleurs de plumes allant
du noir au blanc en passant par le brun
ou de la feo mélanine
voilà quarante qui concerne le reste des
couleurs pour le moment nous n'avons
aucun moyen de savoir si elles étaient
présentes ou non pas pour le moment non
c'est donc avec les caroténoïdes que ça
se complique
il en existe plus d'un millier les
caroténoïdes ne sont pas produits par le
métabolisme de l'oiseau viennent de son
alimentation
ça n'exclut pas qu'il peut ensuite être
modifiée par certaines enzymes produites
par l'oiseau mais la molécule de base
matières premières en quelque sorte doit
être ingérée ça implique que si une
espèce d'oiseau est incapable pour x
raisons de trouver des caroténoïdes dans
son environnement
les plumes qui sont censés être colorée
par les caroténoïdes en question ne
pourront pas recevoir ces piments et
donc seront forcément souviens toi que
les différents pigments peuvent
cohabiter au sein d'une même plume et
même parfois se mélange les couleurs des
oiseaux ne sont pas du rachat les
pigments donc les plumes peuvent quand
même contenir d'autres pigments et ce
même s'il ya plus de caroténoïdes
disponibles l'impression que j'étais
perdu oui mais pas ici je te donner un
autre exemple mais simplifie qui fit le
flamand fifi est un oiseau connu pour
son plumage une couleur assez
fantastique
si tu fais une grosse
[Musique]
si flamand donc tirent leur jolie
couleur rose et de leur alimentation
très riches en caroténoïdes en milieu
naturel ces oiseaux mangent les
cyanobactéries des micro organismes qui
en sont remplis
lorsqu'on a voulu les accueillir en parc
zoologique laisse manière de l'époque
leur ont offert ce qu'il pensait être
une nourriture appropriée des algues
comme pour toutes les autres espèces
d'oiseaux aquatiques filtreurs ah non
non non ils sont très bien adaptés les
halles de contenus tous les nutriments
dont ils avaient effectivement besoin
douce mis à part les caroténoïdes des
cyanobactéries du coup et pas troubler
les flamands roses des eaux sont devenus
blancs comme neige
c'est pour cela que depuis ce jour la
nourriture des flamants roses oiseaux
contient ce que l'on appelle du flamingo
raid
autrement dit le pigment contenues dans
les cyanobactéries dans leur milieu
naturel
dans ce cas là oui parce que les autres
pigments sont naturellement absents les
plumes des flamants roses adultes mais
ce n'est pas le cas de mon second
exemple le cardinal rouge cardinal
banane celui là il s'agit d'un petit
passereau d'amérique du nord
particulièrement colorée le mal est
entièrement rouge vif cette couleur est
donnée par un type de caroténoïdes un
pigment qui est donc route mais le
cardinal absorbe aussi un autre type de
caroténoïdes un pigment cette fois jaune
d'habitude le jaune est quasiment
invisible dans les pubs parce qu'il est
caché par le tout montrouge beaucoup
plus présent mais lorsqu'on supprime ce
pigment rouge exactement les plumes du
cardinal 140 mg bid rouges sont donc
faire des tests en laboratoire il n'y a
pas le choix il est impossible de savoir
à l'avancé sur la famille de l'oiseau on
peut avoir une petite idée de ce qu'on
va trouver car souvent des pigments
spécifiques sont partagés par toutes les
espèces appartenant à la même famille
c'est le cas des pigments comme les
ports pierrine et si ta copine et leslie
nissin on les trouve respectivement chez
les touraco les chouettes et hiboux et
qui joue les perroquets et enfin les
manches
normalement oui mais si tu veux tester
il va falloir une lampe à uv pas
l'ips organiques sont des pigments
plutôt rigolo parce qu'ils ont a la
particularité de réagir aux uv et donc
de briller sous une lampe à bp je vous
présente donc notre modèle un hibou
grand duc d'amérique qu'on appellera
pour l'occasion monsieur du duc noter
qu'un autre un modèle portait la
collection automne hiver livrée blanche
tachetée de brun sombre monsieur du duc
donc une lumière cela lui arrive et
certaines plumes du duvet se colore
différemment les deux patchs rouge que
l'on voit ici sont les pains farines
chez les chouettes et hiboux
ces pigments servent de signaux et sont
donc souvent placé sur le dessous des
ailes ou au niveau du duvet où ils sont
recouverts lorsque l'oiseau n'en a pas
besoin et ça marche aussi sur les
pigeons
[Musique]
mais si attend jusqu'à preuve du
contraire tu n'es ni un perroquet unis
un manchot donc non pas de tita coffee
bean 10,2 fini si des noms ça il ne prit
pas comme des porphyres in c'est certain
par contre ce sont des pigments souvent
très vif chez les perroquets les psys
tacot fulmine sont responsables des
myriades de couleur vive qu'on leur
connaît elle remplace même les
caroténoïdes qui sont souvent utilisés
par les autres oiseaux pour donner du
rouge du jaune du rose et outre leurs
couleurs très flashy les petits tacot
fut vie non un autre avantage les perron
qu'ils sont capables de les synthétiser
sans avoir besoin de les trouver dans la
réglementation ah oui plutôt ceux
généralement du jaune mais ne se
retrouvent que chez les manchots en
complément de la mélanine qui leur donne
ce superbe costume
donc voilà pour les pigments chercheuse
on a vu les couleurs structurale des
couleurs plus demandeurs mais il existe
un dernier type de couleurs qui
s'apparente un peu à du maquillage est
bien moins 6
certains oiseaux utilisent des
substances trouver un leur environnement
pour changer la couleur de leur plume un
peu comme on mettrait du maquillage
ici ces vautours à l'origine blanc comme
neige trempent leur plume dans la boue
pour les rendre brune il ce ne sont pas
les seuls les gypaètes barbus utilisent
des eaux chargées en bouffer rose pour
peindre enroulée plumes blanches
autrement leur fait
le dr c'est bien là le faire c'est mieux
certains lagopède cp duty dans la boue
pour ternir leurs plumes blanches
lorsqu'il survient le printemps et donc
la fonte des neiges c'est un bien
meilleur camouflage
c'est tout ça pour dire que la couleur
chez les oiseaux qui passent du simple
et pour mieux comprendre
rien de tel que quelques exemples je
vais donc vous proposer des photos de
coloration anormal chez certains oiseaux
le but étant de trouver quel pigments
sont absents de la bébête
oui pourquoi pas je vais donc vous
mettra chaque fois le phénotype normal
autrement dit de la coloration habituels
de cette espèce et le phénotype anormal
donc l'oiseau qui manquent
et non je vous remets les pigments au
milieu comme anti sèches on va dire
voire 1 on va tester
[Musique]
allez c'est parti
premier cas un corbeau tout blanc notez
les rouges et les patros dû à la couleur
sans que l'on peut voir au travers de la
peau
oui c'est un bon début mais encore eh
bien on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
un bon cet oiseau n'a aucun pigments
radio ni mélanine nicolas rothé nos
rides
nada ça se voit notamment grâce aux
plumes blanches mais aussi aux yeux
rouges qui montre que même les pigments
habituellement présents dans l'iris ne
sont plus là c'est ce qui s'appelle tout
simplement un abîme calimero 2
je vais pas mettre deux fois la même
chose non plus donc réfléchi quand même
deux minutes avant de dire n'importe
quoi et puis j'ai dit quoi au sujet des
yeux ils doivent être rouge pour que ce
soit un albinos ici c'est ce qu'on
appelle un oiseau le cystique chez ces
animaux les pigments ne sont pas
transférés au plus mais ils sont
toujours présents dans le corps de
l'oiseau comme en témoignent les colorer
normalement ainsi que les pattes
ce qui est très amusant que les oiseaux
le sist hic c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
tout blanc chez certains seuls quelques
plumes non pas aussi de pigments ce qui
donne des oiseaux colorés normalement
avec des taches blanches un peu
n'importe où c'est ça allait gagner
rires en croit en un sens oui exact
c'est bien sûr plus de mélanine qui
conduit l'oiseau à être beaucoup plus
sombre que la normale seul fonctionne
plus ou moins comme chez les mammifères
puis il y avait la ligne plus l'oiseau
sera sombre en fonction du type de
mélanie d'un excellent et on distingue
deux sortes de mécanismes le mécanisme
si c'est le mélanine qui est un surplus
et le fait aux mécanismes si c'est la
feo mélanine quitte en surplus parce que
tout le mélanine a été remplacée par de
la fio mélanine une membrane
rappelez-vous l'oiseau ne peut pas
produire les deux types de mélanine en
même temps donc d'un oiseau ne peut pas
avoir à la fois de le mélanine et de la
feo mélanine en excès s'il a trop de feo
mélanine ça implique donc qu'il ya moins
de mélanine donc moins des pigments
noirs et bruns foncés
bon c'est passer le temps sur la
mélanine passons au cas suivants prêts à
les cas numéro 4 a été fait exprès c'est
pas possible c'est une perruche
il appartient au même groupe que les
perroquets nécessité 6 d
la bio et chants du lait est un oiseau
naturellement en vert et jaune avec
quelques motifs noirs sur les deux là le
dos et les jours par sélection les
éleveurs de pleurnichant produit des
colorations différentes la première de
ces mutations étant la perruche ondulée
bleues et blanches 6 mai chez la
perruche ondulée le verre n'est pas dû
seulement activement en réalité le ver
que nous voyons et la somme de 2 types
de coloration un pigment jaune et
microstructure des pme donnant une
couleur bleue la combinaison des deux
donne du verre comme de la peinture
bleue et de la peinture jaune donne du
verre si on retire donc ce qu'il mange
on à la perruche il reste la
microstructure des plumes qui reflètent
la lumière en donnant du bleu la
perruche et dont bleus ah bah oui du cap
où john c'est bon ça c'est du concept
je crois qu'on va arrêter là pour
aujourd'hui c'est déjà pas mal
d'informations en une fois et encore je
vous ai épargné toute la machinerie
cellulaire responsable de la production
et de l'utilisation de ces pigments
c'est très intéressant mais ça regarde
solides bases en biologie moléculaire et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas trop le temps
j'espère que ce petit plongeon dans le
grand nombre de la pigmentation à vienne
vous aura montré pourquoi retrouver les
couleurs exactes des dinosaures facile
mais c'est pas si facile
il existe beaucoup de variations de
coloration chez les oiseaux et il est
quasiment impossible de toujours en une
seule vidéo j'ai fait qu'effleurer la
surface de ce qu'on connaît actuellement
médecine ce jeu vous intéresse je
répondrai volontiers à vos questions
dans les commentaires
souvenez en savoir un peu plus sur la
biologie des réseaux il existe ce livre
qui couvre la plupart des bases en
ornitho et qui est parfait pour débuter
alors attention à la classification des
oiseaux qui se trouve à la fin parce que
ce livre date quand même de 2006 et
évidemment on n'avait pas encore toutes
les connaissances qu'on a maintenant
donc faites juste très attention à ça du
coup je remercie encore une fois l'ami
qui m'a offert ce livre il ya déjà pas
mal d'années et pour tous les autres on
se retrouve la prochaine fois pour
nouvelles infos sur les roseaux à plus
[Musique]